hey gamer welcome to 2016 in the future
of journalism opinions from influential
individuals influencers breaking news
I'm so wet I'm so drained because of all
of these leaks follow the story live on
Twitter and then send us your snapchats
via the comment it's exactly what you
thought but different ha ha
that's right journalism fans it's time
to get high if you play games you're
more than aware of pipe and its
influence over the way we anticipate
them once a game is released there are
dozens of ways of assigning it value
being review scores a friend's
recommendation or even sales but before
a game comes out pipe is its only
currency so up until the game comes out
it's basically the only metric that
matters to publishers that's all they
want to know how many people are excited
for our next game this information
directly impacts everything from
marketing spans to development time and
the frequency by which trailers and
gameplay footage are trickled out for
public consumption but that's not where
hypes influence stops in fact it's most
caustic effects can be seen in games
coverage for games websites youtubers
and streamers hype is a crucially
important currency games with hype get
views and more views means more
advertising revenue so if the game is a
lot of hype behind it somebody reporting
on games has a financial incentive to
make sure they cover it a lot this is
why your feed was filled with thousands
of fallout 4 videos for half of last
year because hype equals cash in fact if
I had to guess I'd say anticipating this
crazy runaway hype train is exactly why
Bethesda chose to enhance the game a few
months before its release but regardless
of how many of us haters the reality is
that hype is a powerful force in 2016
it's a machine where gamers publishers
in the press each act as a cog but
what's the net cost of all of this hike
is it harmless is it a necessary evil or
is life actually ruining your enjoyment
of game
I'm Daniel Dwyer you're watching the
point and this week I need the mic
machine broke
we all have our favorite game series
those which fascinate us so much that
we'll read or watch just about anything
about them but for games we've already
played for the movies we've already seen
reading stuff about them doesn't impact
on the experience we originally had with
them it doesn't take away from the
enjoyment we've had because well we've
already had it but anticipation is a
much more malleable thing forceful
enough to affect our enjoyment of
something before we've even experienced
it we all like looking forward to things
vacations birthdays visits from distant
friends sometimes these events can
result in disappointment usually through
things that are out of our control like
weather or accidents but for the vast
majority of these life events our
expectations align with the eventual
reality this is because we're in control
we chose what to do where to go so the
reality isn't a letdown because it's
close to what we anticipated simply said
it matched our expectations so when
we're in control the thing we're looking
forward to we're not often let down and
disappointed by it okay well that's good
to know but what happens when we're not
in control the media we consume is
outside of our control we may be fans of
a game series film director or musician
but ultimately the quality of work they
produce isn't up to us and it's when
something is out of our control that we
have trouble aligning our expectations
this is why you order takeout from the
same three places because being
disappointed sucks nobody likes it but
when your expectations are accurate that
doesn't happen when what you think
you're getting on what you get are the
same and when the sesame fried chicken
tastes consistently good why risk being
disappointed but media doesn't work like
that media is unreliable and musicians
new album can send different the
directors new movie may take some crazy
new creative risks and new games of so
many moving parts that gauging
expectation can be incredibly difficult
and the thing is our enjoyment of games
isn't just based on how good a game is
it's critically connected with our own
personal expectations sometimes the game
has hyped up so much that no matter the
quality it falls short of those
expectations while a mediocre game
you've never heard of could be a lot of
fun because you weren't
baiting much from it in fact sometimes
we expect so little from a game that
when it comes out and is actually half
decent or pleasantly surprised by it
just look at last year until dawn a game
nobody expected editing of became a
critical sleeper hit based almost
entirely on low expectation the order
1886 a game that had been marketed to
intentionally obfuscate the fact that it
was a glorified rail shooter was panned
by gamers once it came out because it
fell short of the expectations laid out
by its marketing campaign on the
flipside rocket League was so much more
fun at launch because none of us
expected it to be that good I mean are
you really telling the Assassin's Creed
syndicate didn't benefit from being a
follow-up to a whole bunch of mediocre
Assassin's Creed games people liked that
game not simply because it was good they
liked us because it was better than what
they were expecting but the most
powerful games are the ones that have
high expectations that they somehow
managed to reach that's the difference
between games like the tremendous
witcher 3 and phantom pain as compared
to say fallout 4 a perfectly good
fallout game that aligned with most fans
expectations this is why madden and Call
of Duty are so popular they consistently
deliver a mediocre expectation it works
for reviewers sue this is why these
games always get 8 out of 10
90 years they do a little more or 70
years they fall short it's all about
expectation and hype is at the forefront
of this hype is a mechanism that aims to
change your expectations to get you
excited for a game not so that you'll
enjoy it more but so you'll preorder it
and buy the season pass and drop an
extra $60 on a special edition pipe is
there to make money it doesn't serve
your happiness hype isn't going away
anytime soon the way we buy and talk
about games is too entrenched in its
mechanisms but what we can do is limit
its ability to inform our expectations
so this year when you look forward to
games like no man's sky The Last
Guardian Mirror's Edge catalyst or the
division curtail your expectations try
and ignore the marketing powers that be
the hundreds of news posts never-ending
horrid of trailers and exclusive game
play premieres and meme videos and
sponsored streams
keep your expectations healthy and
you'll be rewarded with a better game
for it we can't turn off the hype
machine but you can choose to ignore it
thanks so much for watching this week's
episode of the point we're super happy
to be back in 2016 every other Friday of
course let us know what you think of
this week's topic the hype machine and
the comment box below I'll be diving in
there myself of course you can always
reach out to me on Twitter at Danny
McGuire or contact me anonymously via my
tumblr the point will be back in two
weeks but until then myself a nominee
who make this show I've just taken over
production of GameSpot's weekly
discussion show the lobby so if you want
more hot videogames question I pipe and
make sure you check out the lobby on
GameSpot calm or check out the full
shows or the break ads on YouTube I will
see you in the comments and thanks so
much for supporting the show see you
then